>>> NEW LIES ABOUT THE PANDEMIC
HAVE SILENCED THE CONTROVERSIAL
CONGRESSWOMAN FROM ONE OF HER
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS AT LEAST
FOR NOW.
MAR
MARGE RRY TAYLOR GREEN HAS NOW
BEEN SUSPENDED FROM TWITTER.
>> THE GEORGIA REPUBLICAN IS
AGAIN DEALING WITH THE FALL-OUT
OVER HER LIES AND MISLEADING
STATEMENTS.
THIS TIME ABOUT THE COVID
PANDEMIC.
AS WE MENTIONED, MARJORIE TAYLOR
GREENE HAS BEEN SPOUTING OFF
ABOUT THE VACCINES IN
PARTICULAR.
TONIGHT SHE'S CLOSER TO HAVE HER
TWITTER ACCOUNT SUSPENDED
PERMANENTLY.
>> THANK YOU FOR COMING,
EVERYONE.
>> CONGRESSWOMAN MARJORIE TAYLOR
GREENE HAS BEEN SPREADING LIES
AND MISINFORMATION ABOUT THE
PANDEMIC FOR MONTHS.
>> DR. TONY FAUCI FUNDED WITH
YOUR TAX DOLLARS, HE FUNDED IT
IN THE WUHAN LAB.
DIDN'T HE?
HE FUNDED COVID-19.
>> AND TONIGHT SHE HAS ONCE
AGAIN RUN AFOUL WITH TWITTER,
THE SOCIAL MEDIA GIANT
SUSPENDING THE GEORGIA
REPUBLICAN'S ACCOUNT FOR A WEEK,
THIS TIME FOR HER TWEETS SAYING
THE FDA SHOULDN'T APPROVE COVID
VACCINES AND, QUOTE, THESE
VACCINES ARE FAILING AND DO NOT
REDUCE THE SPREAD OF THE VIRUS
AND NEITHER DO MASKS.
BEFORE THE SUSPENSION, TWITTER
ISSUED A DISCLAIMER AT THE
BOTTOM OF HER TWEET SAYING THIS
TWEET MAY BE MISLEADING.
>> TWITTER DOESN'T GIVE THREE
STRIKES.
THEY GIVE FIVE STRIKES.
RIGHT NOW SHE IS ON HER FOURTH
STRIKE.
>> RESPONDING TO THE SUSPENSION,
GREENE ISSUED A STATEMENT.
>> I HEARD ALABAMA MIGHT BE ONE
OF THE MOST UNVACCINATED STATES
IN THE NATION.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> IT ALL CAME RIGHT AFTER
GREENE KEPT SPOUTING LIES ABOUT
DR. ANTHONY FAUCI AT AN EVENT IN
ALABAMA.
>> HE FUNDED COVID-19.
THE GAIN OF FUNCTION RESEARCH,
THAT IS HIS BABY, THAT IS HIS
EXPERIMENT.
AND HE'S GETTING TO WATCH IT IN
THE REAL WORLD.
>> GREENE IS HARDLY THE SOLE
OFFENDER.
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS HAVE
FACED CRITICISM FOR MONTHS FOR
LETTING USERS PUBLISH
MISINFORMATION ON THE PANDEMIC.
>> PRETTY MUCH EVERY DIGITAL
PLATFORM HAS STRUGGLED WITH
COVID MISINFORMATION SIMPLY
BECAUSE THERE IS SO MUCH OF IT.
WE SEE THERE IS STILL A LARGE
NUMBER OF ACCOUNTS THAT ARE
CONTINUING TO PUBLISH VACCINE
MISINFORMATION, COVID
MISINFORMATION THAT HAVEN'T BEEN
BLOCKED.
>> MATT SAYS HIS FIRM NEWSGUARD
TECHNOLOGIES, WHICH TRACKS
MISINFORMATION ONLINE, HAS FOUND
SEVERAL EGREGIOUS EXAMPLES ON
THE COVID PANDEMIC OVER THE PAST
YEAR AND A HALF.
>> EARLY IN COVID LAST YEAR,
THERE WERE -- THERE WAS A
CONSPIRACY THEORY SPREADING ON
FACEBOOK AND OTHER PLATFORMS
THAT 5G CELL PHONE TECHNOLOGY
WAS THE CAUSE OF COVID-19.
AND PEOPLE WERE BURNING DOWN
CELL PHONE TOWERS IN THE U.K.
BECAUSE OF THAT CONSPIRACY
THEORY, WHICH HAD NO BASIS IN
FACT WHATSOEVER AND JUST TOOK
ROUTE IN THESE, YOU KNOW, PAGES
AND GROUPS ON FACEBOOK AND OTHER
PLATFORMS.
>> THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS
CRITICIZED THE SOCIAL MEDIA
GIANTS FOR NOT DOING ENOUGH TO
BLOCK COVID MISINFORMATION.
PRESIDENT BIDEN AFTER SAYING
LAST MONTH THAT FACEBOOK AND
OTHER PLATFORMS ARE, QUOTE,
KILLING PEOPLE LATER WALKED THAT
COMMENT BACK.
HIS SURGEON GENERAL ACKNOWLEDGED
THAT WHILE SOME HAD MADE SOME
EFFORT TO BLOCK OR REDUCE COVID
INFORMATION --
>> THAT IT'S NOT ENOUGH.
THAT WE ARE STILL SEEING A
PROLIFERATION OF MISINFORMATION
ONLINE, AND WE KNOW THAT HEALTH
MISINFORMATION HARMS PEOPLE'S
HEALTH.
IT COSTS THEM THEIR LIVES.
>> WE REACHED OUT TO FACEBOOK
AND TWITTER FOR RESPONSE TO THE
CRITICISM THAT THEY'RE NOT DOING
ENOUGH TO STOP COVID
MISINFORMATION.
TWITTER DIDN'T RESPOND
SPECIFICALLY BUT HAS RECENTLY
CITED ITS POLICY THAT FALSE OR
MISLEADING CLAIMS MAY NOT BE
SHARED ON TWITTER AND IT CAN AND
DOES LABEL THOSE TWEETS
MISLEADING.
SOMETIMES DELETES TWEETS OR
SUSPENDED ACCOUNTS.
FACEBOOK TOLD US THE CRITICISM
NEGATES THEIR EFFORTS TO FIGHT
MISINFORMATION, BUT FACEBOOK HAS
ACTUALLY REMOVED 18 MILLION
PIECES OF COVID MISINFORMATION
AS LABELED OVER 167 MILLION
PIECES OF FALSE CONTENT AND HAS
CONNECTED OVER TWO BILLION
PEOPLE WITH GOOD INFORMATION ON
THE PANDEMIC.
TH